all right Charlie Charlie Jones Charlie
you were the warden at home in prison in
Atmore Alabama right how many years were
you the warden at Holeman 30 oh well I
was warden for 18 I worked in the prison
system for 35 35 years and you grew up
where in Alabama right here you tell me
about your childhood yeah both your
parents yeah
how'd you describe your childhood oh
just normal
I went school finished school went to
college finished it come back here
built a house and I'm nine miles from
the prison I live here most of the time
I've been moved around all over the
state it different prison how many
prisoners did you have at home in
Proxmire a thousand and you at death row
inmates at holman right Homans the only
prison in Alabama that has right the
death penalty his executions right as
warden for 18 years what's your view on
the death penalty
do you see it as an effective way to
control crime or keep keep keep society
in line
well I think you have two bad cases huh
you can't you know for certain saying
you can do other things but the way
death row was set up it's pretty bad you
have to have pretty bad crime to be put
on death row you have to have a
combination of murder robbery murder
rape or something like that for you
qualify for
but sooner or later these other nonsense
crimes in my view have to be done other
ways because the the taxpayer not gonna
pay to have all of them locked up too
many of them it gets expensive right
yeah so as warden at Holmen part of your
job was to perform the executions right
right you're using the doctor chair or
lethal injections it was a chair so by
the time a man gets to the electric
chair where do you see your role his the
end of his life do you that you're the
one that's pulling the trigger well
technically I guess I would but a lot of
things happen between the time and he's
arrested in the time he has to sitting
that year it's a long drawn-out process
that can last as long as 20 years
sometimes longer than that there's a lot
of steps a suspect would have to go
through before he sits in the electric
chair right yeah a crime committed then
there there's an investigation and then
they followed the investigation until
they arrest somebody and then he's
arraigned and then he tried and 12
people said in judgment on him and if
he's convicted he goes to prison Oh
death row then his appeal process starts
and it is long and drawn-out Alabama
Supreme Court Court of Criminal Appeals
state court it can last I only know so
by the time he gets to the electric
chair it's it's pretty certain that this
is that he's guilty by the time yeah
well not always there's some time they
can go right up pretty close to the time
and the attorney come up with something
that he appeals one last time to the
Alabama Supreme Court and they give him
a stay he don't always last my last a
day my last week my last three or four
years but most of the time once I'm
served or was served with a warrant a
death warrant then it's getting really
serious I get that warrant 30 days prior
to the date and now during that time the
attorneys for both sides they they get
busy and they try to come up with
something to stop it sometimes they do
and by that time most times they didn't
what is that death row inmates last
moments like before before he is
executed you describe that well you you
talk about the day of the day of yeah
well the day of the inmate would spend
most of the day with his family on the
asian yard we leave him out there
approximately two hours before the time
to get him ready and we take him off the
vision yard escort him back to his cell
the execution team would get him dressed
shave his head shave his ankle left
ankle and get him ready by that time
it's right around 12 o 12:00 a.m. 12:00
or 1:00 a.m. and then they would call me
I'd be in my office I stayed in my
office 12:00 a.m. to midnight
yeah I'd stay in my office while they
did that in case we got a call from the
governor from the Attorney General or
from the court putting it all
if we didn't then somebody would man the
phone while I would go to the death
chamber by the time I got down there
they've got him in the chair strapped in
ready to go by law I had to read that
death warrant to him and I would ask him
if he had any last requests or or
statement most of them didn't Oh
if not then I would tell the two
officers in the death chamber to make
him ready
final final readiness was putting the
helmet on him and putting the ankle
bracelet on him and then I would leave
the death chamber go in next door to the
equipment room
the two officers would come out I didn't
wanna leave anybody in there with him
for fear that somebody might pass out
and fall into him and won't say come out
they'd give me a signal tap on the door
and it was all over it's just a flip of
a switch press of a button press of a
button how did this affect you
personally doing this well yeah how many
did you perform I did 17 man and one
woman how did it affect you personally
well that's a good question
I I've never let their problem become my
problem and I didn't put them there I
didn't go out and arrest them and sit in
judgment on them once they got there
that was their problem and they knew
that and I tried to treat them in such a
way and had my staff treat them in such
a way that when the time came you know
we didn't have to look away from him we
could look him in the eye
and let them know what fiction take
place and what to watch for and you know
here comes and afterwards you know it it
it lays on your mind did me but not a
guilt thing just hoping that I had done
everything to be sure that his case was
perfect and it could be that there was
in no way me or my staff the cause of
him having to sit in that chair when
maybe he shouldn't have if he shouldn't
have then it was somebody else's
mishandling not us so you know I I don't
lose sleep over it to tell you the truth
very seldom think about it what kind of
reactions would you see from the men as
they approach the last day not not a lot
most of them was ready they would you
know we would take them out of their
regular cell 24 hours ahead of time and
put them in what we call the ready cell
the death cell once we got him down
there and they were away from all their
friends on the cell block they settle
down really well I can only recall one
that seemed like he he cared a grudge to
the chair but the rest of them didn't
they they let it go and most of them at
one time or another during a short
period meted what they'd done
eventually they admitted their crimes
yeah yeah not all of them but most no is
there one in particular that stood out
in your memory
yeah but I can't recall it name hey
y'all
you think people that cared I don't know
what you'd call it but they've mad all
the time and be careful how you spoke to
them you say good morning to me get mad
at you that's kind of the way that guy
will what do you think the core cause is
of a hardened criminals behavior I mean
do you think it was his environment or
his family or his brain chemistry what
do you think is the cause of what makes
it criminal I don't know if I knew that
I could probably rest easy rest my life
I don't know I think it's a combination
of things I think a lot of them grew up
without a father
not knowing who their father was and
getting with the wrong crowd as they
grew up taking making bad choices and
going around trying to take away stuff
it didn't belong to it all goes hand in
hand doesn't it good long it all goes
hand in hand it's you know to aintry
quick and I think it is a combination of
all it and you're retired now but but in
your decades of working in the prison
system what what how have you seen
criminals change I mean DDC they're more
violent how are they different now than
they were in the past
Oh drugs are a bigger part of the
picture now right the drugs are a bigger
part of the picture oh yeah most of not
on death row but regular population most
of the inmates in the regular population
it it maybe didn't come to prison
because of
but drugs was always involved how do you
look at this part of your life that you
that you have I mean there's this
chapter of your life it's certainly very
unusual how do you view it well I guess
I look at it like anybody else looks at
something that they do a farmer or
whatever it's something that I did and I
knew what it was when I took the job
it wasn't no surprise you know I knew
that eventually that I'd have to do that
and now you know I look back on it and I
know I did everything I could to say
that they were treated not just their
death row but all of them they were
treated right wasn't abused and at the
same time no we didn't we didn't let
them to us that way either
but we didn't have that much trouble and
I look back on that is that I did all I
could to be sure they they were treated
right I've met him on the street and
they would run to me with a handout and
you know if somebody might recognize
some of my dating and they'd have to
tell me everything were I've had some of
them tell me you know I die I kept them
from getting in bad trouble in prison
and I knew by something I could gauge
what I did maybe maybe I did all I could
do what was right I don't I don't have
any regrets or anything
and the main thing I mentioned a while
ago I did not let people put me on the
guilt trip
about what I had to do and I did not
allow the inmates problem to become my
problem they had to do what they had to
do I did what I had to do and they just
have to let the rough in Drey all right
charlie
thank you so much for for talking with
me very interesting thank you
you